head she is a survivor and a singer
catchy okuchi is a guest starring on
america's got talent las vegas live
stage this week inspiring audiences with
her story and her beautiful voice
welcome catchy thank you
for being here we are honored you are
okay let me let me go down the run down
okay you were a season 12 finalist yes
america's got talent a finalist on
america's got talent the champion
and now i'm calling it you're an
all-star
okay best starring in the live show at
the luxor yes it's a lot of fun it's a
show for like
there's something for someone of any age
basically and they're different kinds of
acts not just singers there's like you
know people that do stunts and just
dangerous stuff it's just really fun and
i'm really honored to be part of that
cast oh my gosh you've been a part of it
for so long now when did you start to
sing where did this all be begin well it
kind of started with like child i mean
everyone loves music right yeah i grew
up with music and then after my accident
when i was 16 my voice kind of went
through a weird change that made me able
to kind of sing a little better it was
very weird i couldn't really explain it
medically but like i just ran with it
and then from there i started singing
just for fun and then eventually um one
of my best friends signed me up for a gt
and that's how i ended up on their radar
and now here we are that is incredible
and you said you can't explain it
medically but i would say that is a you
just can't explain that at all that is
spiritual exactly that's what i think
anyway i think it's like a miracle it
was a miracle it was a miracle how has
how has adt changed your life it's given
me opportunities that i just never would
have had without the show it's exposed
me my story in so many ways and now i
have a chance to sing
every day you know for
different people different audience i
mean it's really just a dream come true
to be able to share my passion with so
many people through america's got talent
so i'm just grateful wow well welcome to
vegas thank you we are going to catch
you on stage this week yes what should
we expect from your performance you
should expect inspirational
type vibe you know i like that we like
that and um hopefully something that
makes you feel like you know just
encouraged and hopefully there's a wow
factor in there somewhere too you are
the wow factor girl you are the moment
i love the outfits and everything the
whole thing is just really fun and you
know it's my first vegas like
performance type thing so i think it's
just really cool and full circle that it
has to do with agt so that is incredible
how does that feel for you to be
performing live in las vegas i mean this
is like this as a performance right it's
like a performance capital really you
know this is where people come to like
put on shows this is where people come
to for a vacation to go see shows and to
realize people are coming to see
america's got talent you know vegas live
and then they're going to see me as part
of that cast is the coolest thing
because now i can say you know i
performed in vegas you know and it just
makes me feel really cool and like i
feel like i can be taken more seriously
as a singer now i can add this to my
repertoire you know so absolutely that's
very cool well can we can we before we
before we go can we go back to your
story the accident that you mentioned
you know when you go see her on stage
you're not watching justice singer you
are watching a survivor can you explain
what happened and just and just let
people know that they're seeing
something really special on stage um so
um the accident happened when i was 16
years old i'm nigerian it happened in
nigeria it was a commercial plane
regular airline you know um and it was a
local flight heading home for christmas
in 2005 december with 109 other
passengers 60 of whom were students from
my high school i went to a boarding high
school and unfortunately the plane
crashed and exploded and took the lives
of 107 109 people on board so just
myself and another lady survived no
other kid from my school survived so
lost a lot of friends and essentially
got third degree burns over 65 percent
of my body so um it was obviously a
struggle to survive since then and i've
had so much help and support and my
journey has been a very long one from
2005 till you know 2022 but
every day is better and i'm just
grateful to everyone who has been part
of the journey of making me the person i
am today you know and healing me in this
very complete way so yeah it's really
been it's been a journey and i'm happy
that i can talk about it now in a
positive way oh my god we're so thankful
you can talk about it now and when you
when we watch you on stage when we hear
you saying you know even though that's
healing you i think you're healing us i
hope so yeah i hope so wow well thank
you so much catchy why can't we catch
you on stage oh you can catch me today
tonight um friday all the way to
saturday there's no questions on
saturday and uh follow me on social
media type catchy you'll find me there i
have a book that just came out if you
like to read please check it out too
it's called more than my scars and i
have music and just yeah follow me and
let's go into this journey together oh
my gosh i cannot wait thank you so much
for being here catchy oh it's been a
pleasure julian i will send it to you